now the Prime Minister has announced 40
million pounds of more funding to fix
flood defences in regions affected by
extreme weather this Christmas but a
leaked documents in the observer
newspaper today says ministers were
warned weeks beforehand that spending
cuts could leave thousands of extra
homes at risk of flooding I enjoy now by
the financial secretary to the Treasury
David cork and a very good morning to
you now notwithstanding this 40 million
pounds this this memo the observers got
its hands on I mean it's indisputable
isn't it that overall funding for flood
defences has been cut no that's not the
case the reality is that if you look at
what we're spending on flood defences
it's going to be more over the course of
this Parliament than it was in the last
Parliament under the coalition
government and the coalition government
actually spent more on flood defences
than the last under the last part of the
Labour government so spending spending
hands where it does depend how you add
it all that doesn't mean if you look at
I mean this is coming from the
Association of drainage authorities
which is everyone involved in it saying
the environment agency's funding for
maintaining flood assets has fallen by
fourteen percent the National Audit
Office total funding has declined ten
percent they're not making that up was
it i think that report was was written
or that submission was written in the
run-up to the autumn spending review
when we set out on 2.3 billion pounds
that were spending over six years on
flood defences so you know obviously was
making the case for more money on flood
defences and indeed the autumn spending
review set out more money for flood
defences and say we're spending an
unprecedented amount on our flood
defences today we've got the
announcement from the Prime Minister of
an additional 40 million pounds in
respect of repairing flood defenses that
have been affected by the recent storms
but the reality is that we are spending
more now the reason we can do that is
because the economy is stronger and we
can we've got users to do it but but
even in the last Parliament where we
faced no significant difficulties with
the public finances capital spending on
flood defences priests in real terms I'd
say depends where you start from but you
know I mean we have the Prime Minister
statement company
ago while he was standing in his well
he's on the Somerset Levels talking
about whatever it takes the fact is
you're a Treasury man it's not whatever
it takes there is a unlimited pot
ultimately isn't there for flood defence
spending well if you look at what we're
doing at the moment in response to the
storms that we've seen and ania
extraordinary December in terms of
rainfall but we have seen the bell win
for me to come into place which means
that we're we're funding local
authorities for the expenditure that
they are putting in that we're providing
support two households that have been
affected we're trying to make sure that
that money goes out the door and get
support to people as quickly as possible
we've got the announcement today in
terms of flood defenses so of course yet
it's always a question of priorities but
providing support to those who have been
affected by floods and ensuring that
we've got strong flood defences is
really important and what we're going to
see is is 1500 flood schemes over the
next six years helping three hundred
thousand households being funders
because we can afford to notice right
and that's what I want to get on to that
because we can afford to do so but of
course some you must be worried but the
direction of the borrowing figures I
mean the last figures we have perhaps
you've had an early look at December's
the last figures we have from November
showed you borrowed what sixty six point
nine billion in the first eight months
of the financial year now doing my mouse
and I want you to help me out with this
with Nicky Morgan in mine dinner times
tables that's just around about 28
billion pounds a month for eight months
so x 12 months how much would you borrow
it's a rule as you know we're all for
all four ministers not to not to do
anything on screen because the one
moment you get it wrong it's never ever
forgot well thank you well let me tell
you let me tell you if you keep
borrowing if you keep borrowing at that
level you'll borrow 96 billion or which
I know you won't over the course of the
financial year but can you hit your
target it's 68.9 the other rule there's
a Treasury Minister I've I must say I've
learned is not to pay too much that
paper too much attention to monthly
numbers because the nature of the public
finances is that you know very often an
item of expenditure falls in one month
or not
the month and so on it is better to wait
to look at what the independent Office
of Budget Responsibility says either as
an autumn statement or two budgets at
the autumn statement that was delivered
not that long ago the obr predicted that
we would be running a surplus by the end
of this in Parliament and that we were
on course for a significant reduction in
boring but no predictions about the
target so I thought I would say as they
not to pay too much attention all right
on the monthly numbers because these
things do vary there's a important month
to come with January where we got a lot
of tax receipts in yeah we'll see where
we are all right at the budget maybe
we'll talk then let me ask you though I
mean I read the Prime Minister's New
Year's message with interest he talks he
seems fairly optimistic as you are about
the economy just you know give us a
reality check here there are some
icebergs out there out there you know
we've seen the Federal Reserve raise
interest rates we know we don't know
which way the Bank of England is going
to go when it's going to go we know
they're going to go up that could be a
bit of a shock to the system and bigger
existential threats in terms of what's
happening with China and the eurozone
well the first point to make is that
there are also some very encouraging
things about the economy well we got all
those from the Prime Minister Lee ind
but we shouldn't forget that we've got
employment at record levels for example
that is an important fact but you are
right to say that there are always risks
that are out there which is why for
example you have to use the relatively
good years than the economy to make
progress in improving the public
finances you mentioned the US Fed
putting up interest rates they've done
that because they think that the US
economy is is strong and it be fair to
say that the US economy is that is
forecast to be the fastest growing
economy in the g7 in 2015 alongside the
UK so we do face so that in itself is
probably not discouraging but of course
there are international risks there
often are and we need to ensure that we
build a strong economy as possible that
means sorting out the public finances it
means having an enterprising dynamic
economy that's good for business and
that's what exactly what we're
delivering and that's why it is worth
pointing out the progress we've made in
terms of employment in terms of reducing
the deficit but of course there's more
to do
someone else you a quick question we're
talking about business and trading
partners and things like that about
Saudi Arabia are you shocked by those
executions 47 executions in one go
including including a senior sheared
cleric well clearly it is a very
worrying development and we oppose a
capital punishment in this way we think
that that is that is wrong I'd also make
the point in terms of Saudi Arabia is
that when it comes to protecting British
people the Prime Minister has made it
clear that intelligence from Saudi
Arabia has helped save lives and protect
people in the UK we do have the
relationship we look at our business and
trading well we have a relationship with
Saudi Arabia where we are able to speak
candidly to them where these issues are
raised on a regular basis by the foreign
secretary and the Prime Minister and our
representatives in Riyadh we are able to
have that relationship where we can tell
them at what we think and I have to say
you know clearly is a worrying
development will be further from Saudi
Arabia in the last few days financial
secretary great to see you thank you
very much deep for your time David cool